hey Teresa would you like to grab a bite
to eat
yeah can my boyfriend Roger come hi Tony
I think I love you I love you too as a
friend has this ever happen to you hi
bring Jackson Jackson and Gasing and
together we make Jackson Jackson and
Jackson and we're here to help you get
out of the friendzone today
finally it's a miracle
with just six easy payments of 12 99 we
can help you get out of the friendzone
with 10 simple steps wow what a
reasonable price and seems super simple
it is we'll give you simple steps like
step 1 climb a ladder to symbolically
climb out of the friendzone
don't believe us that it works just ask
this guy after I climbed out of the
friendzone I was finally ready to be the
man that Pam wanted that's not enough
for you then try step 4 by your future
lover flowers every day until they cave
in and love you back
eyeball Marie flowers for 72 days and
then she finally came around or maybe
try step 6
call your future lovers parents and
convince them you are the one after I
call mr. and mrs. Peterson they help me
win my dreamboat so none of those steps
worked for you well here is the best
step of them all step 7
never say Nikki pushing on even if she
turns you down
stony proof no worries take it from
Cindy she tried these steps and now
she's super thrilled actually no I
didn't follow those steps see I realized
a long time ago that if somebody love
you that's just the way it is you're
just gonna have to accept it I mean if
they don't have mutual feelings about
you well it's okay there's nothing wrong
with friendship ah what some people are
just crazy the friendzone is definitely
a
and you should pay us money to help you
get out of it for just seven easy
payments of $24.99 we can help you get
out of the friendzone
today cuz we're Jackson Jackson this
plan is foolproof I married my best
friend who's also my wife I'm not a scam
artist I'm the love doctor
our current president has used this
system to get his wife I'm more
confident than ever can't wait to see
all the new couplings